the only thing that can be short of
about the future is it will be
absolutely fantastic welcome everybody
to the in to the impossible podcast
production of the arthur c clarke Center
for human imagination and the division
of physical sciences at UC San Diego and
it's a treat to welcome Sir Roger
Penrose back to UC San Diego yes yeah
we're back thank you
we're extracting a lot out of you in
this visit we are grateful to you for
hosting to be hosting these many talks
that you're giving you gave one talk
that was more than standing-room-only
earlier today you're doing this
interview now and tomorrow you're giving
another talk
it's really quite generous of you thank
you so much and I've come to expect that
of you you're gracious as always and and
so responsive and it couldn't be a
greater treat to have you affiliated
with our fine University when I was
mentioning to some my followers online
that you were coming I wanted to to
highlight that this is actually the
fifth decade of this book here the
emperor's new mind which is as I pointed
out was the first popular so to speak
science book that I ever read as a as a
teenager in 1989 when it when it first
came out and I've been remarking along
with my friends at how much has changed
but also how little has changed and I
thought we take this opportunity on the
fifth decade of its of its existence on
planet Earth
to kind of review some of the
discoveries that you've had and that
science has progressed since the writing
of the book I know it had a second
edition and other editions since this
first edition that I have here but I
wanted to get a general impression from
you is it did this book exceed your
expectations what did it did it sort of
touch a nerve in the popular
consciousness that it's still a
best-seller to this very day for you I'm
not sure I literally thought that it
might either disappear without trace or
that maybe there would be a little
attention to page paid to it
well it
run about the same time as Stephen
Hawking had written his book yes he a
brief history of time and I remember
asking or noting that that his book had
been had a foreword written by oh yes
and so I thought well I better try and
do something this and the best I could
do I thought well I thought I happen to
know Martin Gardner so right so I
thought it turned me if he wrote a
decent forward I feels prepared to do it
first of all I wasn't at all sure when
they'd be shocked by the point of view I
was ending in fact he was very in
favorite favorable expressed he said he
rather thought of things the same way
and he wrote a very nice forward and
then I thought well perhaps it won't
disappear without trace these some
people will read it I was very naive and
I didn't expect this sort of mixed is
the wrong word there was a lot of
antagonism from certain quarters mmm-hmm
I'm not expected there might be people
who would object to what I've written
from the artificial intelligence
community because I was trying to say it
was a bit more than computation going on
and human thinking and also that I might
have trouble with the religious
community because I was certainly not
expressing a religious for you and I was
trying to go against that somewhat well
he not general legitimate but somehow
that there was something outside science
which had to explain our conscious
beings and so on but I hadn't expected
was a lot of philosophers objected to
what I was saying to I think they just
thought I was too sloppy
I was sort of expecting that there would
be a lot of young people picking up on
the ideas and maybe writing to me or
something my initial experience was
nothing of the sort
they were only old retired people who
wrote to me and they were all retired
people who had time to read the book I
guess and amongst the people not just
lead retired older a few young people
they were usually people who got
inspired by the book one in particular
who became the there was a man known
Michael Michael
who wrote he was intending to have a
series of television programs on based
on the book it ended up been being this
one program but he had as a researcher
somebody who was doing the work and then
he sort of gave up half the way through
and I thought maybe that had a row or
something and he said well actually he'd
become interested in something else and
he actually turned up he became a singer
and he became the lead the leading
singer in Britain tenor tenor singer yes
so I didn't mind him he was like that
one of the people who will have a few
people as a youngster who had written to
me about the book so that's a decent
excuse - yes but one of the main things
that a kiss was a positive aspect of
this was that Stuart Hameroff read my
book right and he more or less wrote to
me to say well the one thing that seems
to be missing from your point of view
was these things called microtubules you
see had risen the book feeling you know
quite I knew about physics and
mathematics and I we try and learn a bit
about neurophysiology and maybe I'll
find enough about it to see where my
ideas had any relevance to that and I
got to the end and I came to the
conclusion I didn't see any relevance
mainly that nerve propagation you see I
need to have preserve and some kind of
quantum coherence
and I just learnt the nerve propagation
wasn't then there's no hope that the
signals there's always big electric
fields which would they cohere you all
your quantum parents get lost in the
rest of the brain and it was completely
hopeless so I sort of had a rather
feeble ending wished and I didn't really
believe in myself but Stuart wrote to me
and said oh you I think the key thing
you're missing is these things called
microtubules so I never heard of
microtubules and I get lots of letters
and email well emails didn't exist in
those days but this is from people
crackpots of one kind or another so I
thought oh here's another you see and
now these things look he's got a picture
of these things look so it must be real
look at the map and I say yeah they're
real
and it seems to me these were structures
far for far far more probable plausible
things which could preserve quantum
coherence I mean it's still a challenge
major challenge but because the fact
there were tubes and the fact they were
symmetrical in various ways and it
looked to me there was a bit much much
better chance there so it sort of
started a collaboration with Stuart and
we formulated this general point of view
called orchestrated objective reduction
objective reduction is something I'd
treated in the book but although that's
one of the things I think that for my
head was not correct hmm there are few
things I would say we're wrong in the
book but not majorly wrong
that is to say it wasn't the right
criterion but it was the sort of idea
which I still believe in namely that
it's gravitation which is the place you
have to look for where quantum mechanics
it needs something to make it consistent
the theory we have at the moment is a
combination of two things which you
should mutually contradict each other
and people sort of live with us and try
to live with it and make sense of it but
they don't normally take the view
there's something wrong which was the
view I took and which I still hold no
and it's really the second book which
was shadows of the mind where I more or
less introduce the microtubules there
and the point of view which I still
believe in is regard to the heart and
picks up quantum mechanics in that the
that the microtubules have sort of a
geometric connection to them or sort of
a natural geometry to them is no
surprise that appeals to your deep love
of geometry but is there something
deeper to it other than there's just
there's geometric structure well I think
there is although it's not being made
use of very much in the legend
developments and it's all really there
that is these structures that are well
actually microtubules come in two forms
they're two different lattices I didn't
know that at the time one of them are
what's called a lattice which is highly
symmetrical
and the others the B lattice which is
not quite so symmetrical it's got a seam
down one edge along the tube whereas the
ones which are highly symmetrical seem
to me have a much better prospect of
preserving quantum coherence so you want
quantum effects to be preserved as a big
level and symmetry is a good way to do
that so when you say the geometrical
structure that's part of it which is
appealing to me and there is this thing
called the yarn teller effect this is
when you have a highly symmetrical
structure well maybe it could be a
crystal like thing or it could be like a
tube with different kinds of symmetries
and the high symmetry means that you can
have well there's a sort of lowest level
of activity which is the sort of lowest
quantum level and that is what's called
degenerate so you have information at
that level it's kind of quantum
information at that level which is
shielded from the next level so there's
a big gap between that level in the next
and you get that when you have very
symmetrical structures and these
microtubules to bandgap yes microtubules
and there's a lot of other problems
which it simply doesn't resolve just
like that but it gave much much more
promise in microtubules than anything
else I've seen before in in
neurophysiology so one thing that
distinguishes your research it's not
without its speculations and and new and
novel ideas but that in almost every
case that I've found in your research
you predict effects which are in
principle possible to prove wrong in
other words they are possible to be
falsified you know to date you've
enjoyed success and that they haven't
been false as many things have not been
falsified and in fact many of your
discoveries have been have stood the
test of time and tests of other
experimental and a mathematical scrutiny
is that something that's important to
you obviously you you know of the
listeners will know of you know popper
karl popper and his his sort of you know
Objectivist and then how do we how do we
determine if something in scientific
well it must be
falsifiable and and and i always point
out that i believe and you talk about
girdle it is incompleteness theorem very
frequently in the emperor's new mind but
I feel like physicists almost have an
envy of girdles and completeness theorem
and then and that we have no way of
objectively showing that our assumptions
are are built upon perhaps in you know
incompatible premises or unprovable or
unfalsifiable axioms and I wonder you
know to what extent to you are you
guided by popper and the falsification
demarcation theory is that something
that's important to you would you work
on something that is not because it
could be tomorrow our colleagues find
that microtubules are just impossible to
be you know they can't maintain
coherence beyond you know nanosecond
level time scale something like that
well you see I think your point is
well-taken but there is a major part of
what I've done in relation to physics
and how it relates to mathematics which
at least as yet has not been falsifiable
yeah and you know I rather go regret for
fact it's not it's like the theory which
I refer to as twister theory now it's
very much motivated by relativity
effects and curious things like the
nature of the celestial sphere you think
of the sky that's a sphere and the
structure of that sky is what's called a
conformal structure and this is a thing
I got interested in very early that if
you imagine two space travelers getting
passing each other very close and they
look at the same sky but they're
traveling and almost very close to the
speed of light one with Israel to the
other and they look up at the same sky
and there's a discourse distortion of
the sky they see the stars are slightly
different spots and so on this I think
elaboration which is to do with emotion
but it has a very curious feature that
it preserves angles not to say if you if
you imagined an angle in the sky if
stood three stars close together and at
a certain angle but the other observer
would see the same angle so it's what
the transformation of one observer to
skies
is what's called conformal and this is a
kind of geometry which I got very
interested in called conformal geometry
I mean we know about your clearly in
geometry that's to do with links and
this is deal with angles and it's a much
richer geometry and the fact that it
applies to the sky is an indication of
something in the completely different
subject the you might say the two big
revolutions of 20th century physics ones
relativity and here we see in special
relativity it doesn't work in Newtonian
Theory relativity they hang the
conformal nature of this transformation
of the sky but the other is in quantum
mechanics and you have these complex
numbers which are all intimately related
to this conformal structure and they
play a big role when you think about
spins of particles and again you get
this same sphere which is a conformal
sphere playing a fundamental role in
physics and this has to do with the
complex numbers which involve the square
root of -1 sort of mysterious numbers
which are at the basis of quantum
mechanics and so I kind of thought of
this is a link between relativity and
quantum mechanics and twister theory I
won't go into it here but it's do it's a
mathematical formalism it has particular
features one of them it's you have to
have three space dimensions in one time
dimension so when I was being confronted
with things like string theory I quite
like the idea when strings were
initially put forward but when they
seemed to consider you needed to have 26
dimensions of space-time or 10
dimensions or both together in some
curious way it didn't appeal to me at
all because the link between the quantum
mechanics and and relativity which is
through this conformal sphere only works
when you have three space dimensions and
one time dimension and so the theory
which I developed which I call twister
theory was based upon this very specific
structure and it doesn't work in other
numbers budget but you can start doing
in another dimension it doesn't really
work and it took me years and years to
try and make it work with general
and only relatively recently that I see
how these things fit together and with
quantum mechanics and curious feature is
that it needs to have this was a big
blow to me initially the cosmological
constant see this was the number
introduced by Einstein in 1917 for the
wrong reason you see he wanted a static
universe he liked a universe which was
sort of spherical in space had closed up
on itself and it sort of sat there
forever and this was just about at the
time when people were becoming convinced
that the universe is expanding but
Einstein introduced this cosmological
constant term usually called lambda like
a V upside down and this was as soon as
he was convinced that the universe was
were actually expanding and this model
doesn't work
he sort of retracted this cosmological
term and regarded it as his greatest
blunder now you see all the cosmology
books we're sort of oh hi Stein says
this number has to be there and so they
all consider it a cosmological constant
so and so and I don't like everybody
else a lot of people thought well it
shouldn't really be there it's much nice
and not having it there and my trying to
solve a big problem in Twista theory I
thought I needed it to be zero and I
remember having this conversation with
with Jerry Ostreicher
and I was saying do we really have to
believe from these stupid distant super
know they were observations of distant
exploding stars supernova that there
seems to be evidence for this expansion
exponential expansion of the universe
over and beyond the expansion that we
already thought was consistent with the
answer on equations and that seemed to
indicate that there was this
cosmological constant that Einstein had
regarded his biggest blunder it had to
be there had to be positive and I said
to Jerry I said well do we really have
to believe that I mean because he
perhaps is just dust out there if as
many people said he looks at me and says
look that's not the point there are so
many things in cosmology that are much
better understood they work so much
better with this cosmological term
and I thought okay I'll give it I'm
prepared to give it up for you say so it
was a good thing because the later views
that I had absolutely depends on having
this cosmological constant it has to be
positive it has to be there we have to
see this exponential expansion and if it
hadn't been for Gerry convincing me it
was there
I've been still going down the wrong
route I was going down before no he's
saying you know Einstein's biggest
blunder turned out to be that he called
it a blunder I guess he wasn't right in
the way he was using in that's right
but it was I mean it was a great insight
because that's basically the only thing
you could do to his equations without
wrecking yeah and I knew you could do
that and he had great confidence in the
equations especially as after the 1919
Eddington Eclipse so in the book one
thing that helped me as a young you know
scientifically mathematically inclined
young person when I read this in 1989
was the way that you very carefully lay
out your your opinions but in a very
even-handed fashion as two different
theories of math and physics and and and
you kind of give a rank ordering to them
which you which you talk about and I
want to revisit that on this you know
yeah so the categories I have them here
entity' v' yes useful and superb and one
of the most amazing things you do is you
start off with Euclid and you say Euclid
Euclidian geometry is actually and it
was in your characterization a physical
theory and I wonder if you can talk more
about that yeah according to yes okay
well mm-hmm
I mean I guess it's an interesting
question how the ancients looked at it I
mean the ideas of Euclidean geometry we
sort of based on angles and lengths and
triangles and sort of the view that a
big triangle in a little triangle the
same geometry applied if you had a
really huge triangle and if you added up
its angles that would still add up to
180 degrees and people tried there was a
big
Timothy where he's no no this chap who
tried to prove that the angles had to
add up I mean it would there you could
realize that there was a puzzle here
that you needed to have a special
assumption which it was the parallel
postulate usually phrased in terms of if
you have a line in the plane and a point
in that plane which is not on the line
then there is only exactly one line
straight line through that point which
didn't meet the other line and and it
was thought that somehow you should be
able to deduce that from the others oh
it was a real insight yeah for Euclid to
see that that was an independent
assumption right and and it took not
just the ancients for many people and
they tried to prove it and Sakaki spent
his entire life trying to prove it at
the end
more or less discovered what's called
hyperbolic geometry and there are other
people who have ski lambert with
somebody who proved beautiful theorems
which had to depend on this other kind
of geometry that people didn't think
existed and about how you have the
angles of the triangle and how much they
fall short of 180 degrees as a measure
of the angle of the triangle carry over
the triangle an amazing thing and how
would you prove a thing like when when
it's don't believe that that there is
any other geometry i don't know it very
interested to know what what lambert
psyche was here i think he probably at
certain times of his life thought there
was a that it was consistent to have two
different times of geometry mm-hm
and other types he probably thought he
was absurd if you had to catch the types
times only thought it was consistent
because he had this beautiful theorem in
it but then and and Gauss who more
importantly tried to find it when he
it's interesting questions because he he
he part of his job was to do geodesy so
he's actually measuring very big
triangles mountaintops and steeples
trying to think oh well he's just you
know to say and he's but I think at the
back of his mind he was really trying to
see whether the geometry was Euclidian
or not
because he knew he knew that there were
other kinds of geometry right and it was
really interesting how the history
people kind of toying with were they
other kinds of Java but the fact that
Euclidean geometry is so precise and it
was sort of laid out is this wonderful
theory which it is an amazing theory and
it lasted for knows how many centuries
yeah before people a discovered there
were other kinds of geometries and be
with Einstein and primarily Einstein but
realizing that you needed to her in
order to describe a physics in which the
principle of equivalence that is again a
thing a lot of these ideas are ancient
but people didn't know quite what
significance was I mean this was going
back to Galileo it's not just going back
to Archimedes and going back to you
Clinton people but the fact that
gravitational field is equivalent to an
acceleration mm-hmm and so yeah it was
extremely insightful and you imagine you
know dropping these things from the in
abode tower or whatever origin they fall
together somehow you can cancel out
gravity and there's a wonderful
description he has in in one of his
books where he talks about fireworks and
you see the fireworks and they explode
and you see these spheres beautiful
spheres and they come they come and they
fall and they remain spheres right and
he pointed this out and there was a deep
insight in that it's just as though
there was no gravity and the
acceleration you if you're free freely
falling it's as though there's no very
experience and that's a huge insight
which had to wait until Einstein took
realize the importance of it yeah that's
right yeah that was in the discourse II
I think the last book that Galileo wrote
yes I wanna read from members new mind a
paragraph that speaks to me to this very
day and I remember being moved by it way
back when he said great works of art are
indeed closer to God than our lesser
ones it is a feeling not uncommon
amongst artists that in the greatest
works they are revealing
truths which have some kind of prior
ethereal existence while their lesser
works may be more arbitrary of nature
more mortal constructions likewise an
engineering innovation with a beautiful
economy where a great deal is achieved
in the scope of the application of some
simple unexpected idea might
appropriately be described as a
discovery rather than an invention
now this harkens back to whether or not
mathematical truths are in some way
discovered or invented and I wonder if
you couldn't weigh in with your vast
experience glean both before and after
this book and where do you feel fall now
well that's certainly I haven't changed
my view in that particularly respect I
mean having certain others yeah I think
the mathematics well it's a platonic
view you would say that the mathematics
has its own world
you see I like to do this with an
illustration which I think first had an
in in shadows of the mind where I had
three types of existence in a sense
and if you're a mathematician you very
strongly get the feeling that it's like
a bit like geology or archeology or
something you're exploring a world no
discovering things which are out there
you don't invent the theorems you
discover truths which are in some sense
out there in a world but it's not the
world the physical world because the
things you find then you know he tried
to draw a triangle and it's not quite
right and how do you draw a straight
line when the more you know about the
nature of matter you see it's granular
in certain respect you're talking here
about what is the number three yes very
difficult and so you when you think
about the mathematics you really have to
think about it in this platonic way it's
not that you're creating it I mean you
sometimes do things which are simply
sufficiently while but they're they look
as though you you've you've met made it
all up in a certain sense if it really
works beautifully there's something out
there which is out of your control and
it's much more like exploration mmm-hmm
you can say this is a feeling that one
has but it's more I think strong you see
this is one of the worlds the world the
Platonic world which of mathematics
which I sort of draws this
at the toxin the picture and then a
little bit of that world it's only a
very tiny bit because if you you know
look at any article and or any Journal
of pure mathematics and you will see the
articles in there which have any
relevance whatsoever to the physical
world very very tiny yeah and the money
I'm gonna Haven them a number in it
that's right and there's a very tiny bit
of it which it sometimes it turns out
later things in Bahamas this beautiful
theorem which was in that pure
mathematical work and now it's found an
application so you see that but when you
think of the whole totality of a
mathematical work that's been done
that's explored if you like it's a
really tiny part of that well they're
very productive magical particularly
magical part of that world which seems
to be and I have it sort of projecting
out to the physical world the laws that
we see being extraordinarily precise
well I say Euclidean geometry is even
though nine we know now not exactly
mirrored in there in the geometry of the
physical world it's a basic ingredient
of everything we think about in geometry
so it has a huge impact into into into
physics mmm-hmm but then the more we
learn about physics its governed by
equations and geometrical ideas and
things and we reduce them to mathematics
and in that mathematics we can gaining
enormous precision in the way we
describe and understand the way the
physical world operates now this is a in
some sense the view we have and this is
the view I have is that this small part
of a mathematical world
encompasses in a certain sense the whole
of the physical world so I draw this in
this rather strange way a little tiny
part of the world the mathematical world
seems to encompass the behavior of this
physical world we've seen it seems to be
when we go to our laws right
they really be it almost is that we
reduce them to mathematics you might say
well what is a what is a rock well this
rock is made of
molecules and things like that and one
of the molecules made a hole in it of
atoms one of the atoms made over there
made of fundamental particles electrons
and and you worry about the neutrons and
protons and then the gluons and things
one way you say well they've but sticks
they're particles together are they
particles themselves well then you're
worried about the photons well you have
these as they used to be feels and then
you see their particles but then you say
what is an electron well the best you
can do is it's a solution of the Dirac
equation you say well that's a pretty
abstract notion you kind of have to
resort to mathematics when you try to
pro reality at this deepest levels and
then there's the next question you see
which is my third world which is the
world of conscious experience and so the
type of view I'm expressing well both in
the Empress demand and chalice of them
and more more explicitly in this picture
is that there's a third world which is
the world of conscious experience some
people take that as primary and they
tried to build everything else out of
that I think that's pretty hopeless task
because the sensory experiences are very
hard to describe any of these other
things in a precise way but nevertheless
that's one you have different ways of
looking at it but again it seems to be a
very small part of the world of physics
which is actually supports consciousness
so okay human being sure I think it's
extends much more broadly than that and
animals may be many animals but not all
animals I wouldn't know but certainly I
think the difference but Heymann beings
and and certain animals is okay great in
certain respects but not fundamental I
think they people are our dog owners for
example a pretty convinced they're dogs
are conscious
I think octopuses are conscious way down
though below that I think mice conscious
- okay nice
you have inter stations of mice and I
say you still live in I think you can
under ma the cleverness of these they
could step over the trap that way
quite deliberately and take out all the
food who didn't clean that and they
hadn't touched the thing which would
trip mess I just had a great admiration
for the mice so there's something which
goes deep down into the into the world
it's still in the Penrose hierarchy of
you know superb useful and tentative
were yes where do you rank because
obviously geometry is superb and
obviously mathematics is superb but
mathematics is I would say you have to
spread it out it's not just mathematics
is itself but do you feel in principle a
theory of consciousness could be superb
is it possible for it to be superb or is
it only possible for it to be useful I
think if we get it right we're a long
way from what would it look like what
would such a theory I all I can say
about it in this did studies of books
I've written is a little chip I would
say and the tiny thing I'm trying to say
is that consciousness well again it's a
little part consciousness in all sorts
of things you know pain and perception
of the color blue and happiness and love
and all sorts of things I don't talk
about most of those things in my book I
just talk about the one thing that I
could say anything about which is
understanding and I concentrated on that
because there are these theorems of
logic most particularly girdle's theorem
and Turing's analysis of obvious in
terms of computation the ideas of
computation and so on leave me to
believe that human understanding is not
computable it's not a computation and
and a lot of people that's where a lot
of people argued with me because somehow
it tells us that an algorithm you see we
have these wonderful computers and what
they can do and they do incredible
things I agree with that but they run on
algorithms this is what we understand
this notion of an algorithm which was
what it really goes back to
well this is Arabic now here is me but
that was during and a few other people
posts and church and people who really
made clear the idea of what an algorithm
it's what a computation is huh and the
girl of theorem tells you that our
understanding is not a computation I
mean this is a story which is you know a
lot of people complain about but I think
the argument is pretty clear that what
we do when we understand a proof in
mathematics is not following an
algorithm and it is very clear because
of the girdle thing right it says
whenever you what do you mean by proof
you see what a proof is using certain
kinds of rules and you have to use them
correctly and if you really think of it
as a proof you've got to believe that
those rules only give you true
statements now it's that thing the
belief is it only gives you true
statements which enables you to
demonstrate the truth of a proposition
which girdle produces very ingeniously a
proposition which you can see must be
true nevertheless it cannot be derived
by means of whatever rules you start
with as long as you believe those rules
could only give you truths then you must
believe this girdle statement is also
true and not derive upon by means of
those rules now when I learnt that I was
tongue stunt
you see it wasn't you can prove certain
things can't derived in certain ways
it's much stronger than that say
whatever procedure you use if it's
following definite rules algorithm which
you believe in you trust algorithm that
you trust then you can see how to
transcend that now what is it in our
abilities to think perceive conscious
perception that transcends computation
although lots of arguments people
presents and one of these as well you
know the algorithm we used in our heads
are so complicated that we will never be
able to see what the girls will thing is
we assure but the point is that how did
it come about by natural selection
it has to have been by relatively simple
things which we can certainly understand
these caught very complicated things
which you can make
having a computer which could do things
which are pretty hard to see why they
true because it's very very elaborate
that's not what was naturally selected
for what was naturally selected for was
this more basic principle of an
understanding and that is not a
computation it's something I don't know
what it is don't ask me what did you
know that's the wrangling between
computability and actual comprehension
and it's the comprehension of why the
algorithm does what it's supposed to do
and it's not simply trying this and that
and that zillions inductively in a
certain sense I mean even irony here
because okay conscious beings came about
in a way by natural selections and which
is it wasn't accurate in some way of
picking out the ones that were more
successful but they were successful in
the new I hold by probing the laws of
physics is a much deeper level than
we've seen yet at this level where we
see non computable action and this has
to be still yeah it was already the
argument I gave in the emperor's new
some new mine but although not quite the
right criterion in my view it has to be
at this place
where we have to go beyond current
quantum theory and the argument came
around which is what formulated the view
basically when I was mine
I think it was my first year as a
graduate student when I went to courses
by man Kosti no mathematical logic
bonding on general relativity and Dirac
a great quantum physicist on quantum
mechanics and I tried to see one in the
physical world can be not fun on the
computer basically and basically my
conclusion was it was this curious
feature of quantum mechanics where you
have a kink insisting it's basically
making a measurement see quantum theory
consists of two parts one is following
an equation the Schrodinger equation and
it just that's something you could put
on a computer unitary evolution
evolution and the other is where you
don't do you make a measurement then to
collapse the wave function and you cheat
but you have to do that right to to
have the world we see mm-hmm and so this
seemed to me that's the place where the
non computable physic has to come in I
don't see and easier heart comes in
mm-hmm and it's a big mystery and my
claim is you've got to harness that bit
and somehow your conscious brain is at
some point making use of this part of
this place it's not just it uses quantum
mechanics many people who prove that
already they say oh no it's classical
physics or you don't know whatever
congregates know what we see that's
wrong already because in things like
photosynthesis and maybe bird migration
there are other places where we seem to
see effects which do just depends on
crucially on quantum effects
well chemistry is already quantum these
are things little bit outside that
saying like room temperature yes
preserving of quantum coherence at room
temperature you so sure the argument is
nature has found a way to do it deep in
the in the brain and much more likely
it'll be to do with microtubules and
probably how they relate to other
structures and so anything with a
microtubule could participate in quantum
mechanical measurement even it doesn't
say that much I mean there are these two
structures the a lattice in the B
licensee a lattice is very symmetrical
mm-hmm I mean that is not so symmetrical
the village is so symmetrical but not so
much and most microtubules in the body
all over the place tend to be B lattice
the a lattice ones seem to be much more
promising for doing things in the brain
probably and maybe conscious actions so
the guess is that whatever is really
responsible for conscious action it's
not just microtubules that a lattice
microtubules and there is some
theoretical work done by various people
which does seem to indicate that mm-hmm
that's certainly for the future I think
that's way ahead of what we have at the
moment other models you know mice or
octopi or yeah I mean are we able to
test and living structures that these
things can occur I mean
schrödinger's cat experiment supervised
by an octopus or something that the
folks at PETA well I think going to that
level is unlikely for awhile for a long
term I think it's much more likely
probing areas of the brain not so much
areas of the brain but exactly what's
going on when and there are things you
know that saw my area of expertise but
there are sort of waves of activity
involving different layers in the brain
and where the conscious activity seems
to come in is where there are large
numbers of these certain kinds of cells
called pyramidal cells and I don't know
enough about it to know exactly there is
a big question
you see which people often raise and
that is there are far more cells neurons
only recently learned it's more I knew
it was comparable yeah in this part of
the brain called the cerebellum the
cerebellum is not people usually but
people you think I was just as part of
the alts convolutions all that it's a
part which looks much more like a ball
of knitting underneath and at the back
it has more neurons considerably more
than and more connections between
neurons and it seems to be pretty well
unconscious mm-hmm it's it's activated
when you do very precise motions you
know if you become an expert tennis
player mm-hmm play the piano beautifully
well you don't think every moment you
know where do I put my middle finger
mean exactly what's what
that's control pretty well my
unconscious actions and the precision
needed in these actions are carried out
by the cerebellum I mean initially you
have to learn about them in this
cerebrum part but when they become
unconscious controlled such with such
unconscious precision that you need at
these great levels of expertise or even
when you're walking down the street
probably certainly when you're driving
the car not thinking about it it's
probably controlled by the cerebellum
mm-hmm now that doesn't seem to be
conscious right what's the difference
well I don't know but Stewart will say
there are no
there are no pyramidal cells in the
cerebellum and the pyramidal cells have
many more microtubules in them and
they're organized in a different way
from those in the that's the kind of
thing one could explore more and see to
what extent is it that these structures
with more microtubules and more a
lattice microtubules may be actually
seem to be more concerned with conscious
thinking and you can definitely true
that some parts of the brain are much
much more to do with consciousness
mm-hmm no that's right
that's certainly true with the
cerebellum mm-hmm I don't know what the
question is with other parts of the
cerebrum you know in a practical level
I'm curious to get your perspective on
recent developments and things like
quantum computing very prescient Lee
talked in this book about not only chess
and this is before deep blue defeated
Garry Kasparov but you talked about the
game go which is which was recently
Google's version of the go playing
algorithm beat it at the best human
human being you talked about all these
things in the late eighties it's really
it's really amusing to look back the
other things you talked about quantum
teleportation there's a charming chapter
we talk about taking the molecules of a
brick and and replacing them and is it
the same brick and then said what's in a
brick in your brain and could you do
these things to this so I'm interested
with all the technological developments
and quantum computing that we've
recently achieved quantum supremacy and
things like that what's your from a
standpoint of the long view of history
how important is this era in modern in
modern times how will you feel like it
will be regarded in the future was this
a critical time or is it it's very hard
for my judge at the moment I mean
certainly the quantum computers that
they have now and they've made a lot of
progress are not like the ones that were
being considered before no you might
have something like a classical computer
and then you're sort of introduced from
quantum superpositions and calculations
and so they're basically different kind
of structure and they're not as far as I
know really Universal machines see one
of them wonderful things about ordinary
computers if I can call the modern
really is depend
this notion developed by Turing in
church and posts and girdle and people
of computability being a universal
concept so you can build up through very
simple ingredients a machine which can
in principle do any computation now this
is this these ideas are developed into
course lots of ingenious ideas going to
it but the modern computers are
basically universal computing machines
right so any kind of algorithm you can
put on the computer that was a condom
machines it's really a very small number
of problems ok the very specific ones if
they can do very well simulate
Hamiltonian as far as I'm aware they're
not really general purpose machines so
it's it's not really quite level maybe
they will become and maybe there will be
a point it's like sometimes comment on
this see in the old days people used to
say well you get better computing this
before the quantum computers you get
better compelling machines the small you
make them so you could get smaller and
smaller chips and then they'd become
smaller and smaller smaller and they
much more effective and you get more
power out of the machine and then
there's a certain limit because at a
certain point you run into the problems
of quantum mechanics and so they were
say the quantum limits you see that'll
stick us at some point well then of
course people say no well once you know
what's going on at the quantum level and
you can actually harness the quantum
level so you have this idea of a quantum
computer which enables you to transcend
least some degree what you can do with a
classical machine and so maybe something
similar might come later on why people
say well there's a certain level a limit
to what you can do with your quantum
machines because it's if you have too
much mass moving around then you're
going to run into the limit where the
quantum mechanics doesn't hold and
you've got to go beyond it and so there
will be a limit there mm-hmm the state
reduction limit of quantum computers
mm-hm
and then maybe someone say well we've
got maybe by then some great theory
which tells you which goes beyond
standard quantum mechanics and then
maybe you can do some construction
device which goes beyond it by taking
advantage of this I think I'm I'm glad
I won't be alive by this I think if
these things do come about I'm not
worried about what I wish you a long
life I wish that that's the only thing I
disagree with you I don't I don't want
you to not to leave the mortal coil too
soon because I I want to see actually
that segues maybe perhaps to my final
question which has to do with all these
various novel ideas that you've had and
perhaps no other certainly no other
modern physicist has had contributions
as diverse as cosmology as consciousness
as twister theory as the talking
computation and artificial intelligence
if you could ask you know as Einstein
used to call him the old one God if you
could if you get the answer to one of
these you know many topics that you've
that you've researched you know
throughout your life throughout your
very productive career which is the
thing that most fascinates you which is
the thing that most captivates your
question because at the moment the thing
which excites me most is the cosmology
mhm but their [ __ ] excites me because
you see I have a certain wild idea which
I think may well be true and most
standard cosmology just don't believe me
you see but there are bits of evidence
were beginning to see which do suggest
that maybe there is some truth in this
model and then just being about the
conscious final listeners you're
speaking about the con formal which says
that the Big Bang was not really the
beginning it was the conformal
continuation I talked about the
conformal geometry were big and small
you're not interested in your own
interests in size what I'm trying to say
is in the Big Bang because the energies
are so big and the particles become
effectively massless they can't tell big
from small so at that stage there's the
kind of geometry doesn't know big from
small is important the other place when
it you can't tell big from small is an
extremely remote future where the
universe expands and expands
exponentially and you mostly photons
running around and they don't know big
from small and you got the black holes
and then they eventually evaporate away
by Hawking evaporation and then you've
got nothing left
it's not quite true you had a little
careful about that but roughly speaking
the idea is that this very remote future
it doesn't know big from small island so
the crazy idea is that this very remote
future joins on to the Big Bang of a
next Eon and our Big Bang was the
conformally squashed remote future of a
previous year that's a completely wild
idea because went instantly well why you
know how does this very stretched out
very rarefied very cold infinite remote
future of a in eon simply become the
very concentrated extremely hot and
dense next big Manning well the thing is
because the geometry there is the
conformal one the big and smaller
equivalent
okay you take people a lot of convincing
to make sure that they believe this but
the claim is that we're making is that
there are certain signals which you can
which do get through and the first ones
we're thinking were super massive black
holes running in huge into each other
and producing huge bursts of
gravitational radiation which would give
you signals which could get through and
we claim that there are such indications
much stronger are the more recent
observations this is different
so one mustn't get them confused the
link between the two is supermassive
black holes but now this is the black
holes in the very future basically
swallowed up an entire cluster of
galaxies and the entire pretty well most
of the mass in that cluster of galaxies
who gets swallowed by the black hole
sits around it sits around it sits
around and eventually gets back rates
away by Hawking evaporation into into
photons you see I used to think it's
very boring phase of the universe when
you've got nothing but black holes left
what's really boring is when they bought
evaporators away and so I was worrying
about this an unbelievably boring
universe and then I think well who's
going to be bored by exactly only the
fur today's a pretty long time that's
right
that's the main point here is that
photons don't experience eternity
because they got no my box and there's a
box yeah they don't have clocks so the
Infinity is no big big deal to a photon
it just zips through into the next he
hung he and that's the view I had then
tried to make it into a theory and these
Hawking points which are the splodge as
I would say may Hawking splotch but it's
pretty circular it would be there would
be spots in the sky about 10 times sorry
8 times the diameter of the full moon
and you wouldn't see them any bigger
than that that's definitely a prediction
of the theory Kane a little bit smaller
mm-hmm but they would be slightly raised
temperature and I don't know this is my
suggestions that if you had a
planetarium you know usually the you see
stars and planets and things like that
have the microwave background on your
planetarium with enough detail yes I
guess the Planck satellite would reveal
and you look at a patent and you would
see them hmm I'd like to know if that's
true we have our beach ball behind you
at all that's right you need a bit more
resolution hmm yes I think the little
spot hate Hansen manometer would
declutter you can prick in that so it
needs to be a bit bigger than that
mm-hmm but the intensity overall is
about 15 times the average increased
temperatures that you see so they knew
the normal variations in temperature 10
to the minus 5 and here you're looking
at about 10 to the minus 4 yeah a little
bit little bit more of an intensity but
probably not too obvious in this and I
would expect you know you look at that
in the sky and you'd see them hmm I'd
like to know I'd like to have a good
world planetarium and I was like to sit
in it yeah I can see well you and I both
have the pleasure at one point or
another speaking at the Hayden
Planetarium and when I spoke there they
were kind enough to project onto the
dome the CMB map is revealed from from
the Planck satellite so we can do they
did do it so maybe we can arrange it for
your next visit to New York City
yeah it's really just a startling it's
almost induced vertigo and me which was
centered on this universe that I had
spent so much time studying I would love
to see yeah it's quite beautiful he said
know where to look for some of them the
finest prominent spots all right I
suppose
and but it's intriguing to know whether
they're whether you would really see
them with the naked eye with with my
crisis and yeah radiation so we were
asking me what yeah I mean that's what
excites me most at the moment because
that's ongoing and you can really see
does this conform to line just a theory
confirmed to the observations or not the
next thing I would say would be the
state reduction experiments which are a
little way off but not that long no
experiments currently being done which
within the next three years maybe we'll
get an answer hmm there are other
experiments the one I'm thinking of
other ones that my duck bomb is Sir
mmm-hmm and this is his estimate and
he's been pretty accurate in predicting
how long his things will be so I think
he may have an answer of course the
answer may be they go the wrong way as
far as I'm concerned but I hope he will
see the state reduction that's a sort of
deviation from standard quantum
mechanics right of course since it's a
dedicated deviation a lot of people will
complain they'll say that's a bad
experiment it's due to decoherence and
all that so I have to you'll have to
persuade them it's a good experiment but
there are other experiments using
bose-einstein condensates I think
they're probably the next maybe they
will see effects mm-hmm right I have a
colleague in Nottingham Yvette parrentes
who has proposals which I hope will be
performed experimental they haven't been
set up yet and the third thing is
consciousness they hit there you see I
think we're a lot longer I think we we
may see the effects in the not
biological experiments but the just the
physical physics experiments are being
done there whether you will see the
quantum effects and microtubules or what
quite possibly I think some general
evidence for quantum coherence
in biological systems might not be too
long from now but to see any direct
evidence of connections with
consciousness I think isn't a long way
oh yeah because that's really such a
slippery subject right to get hold of
that in an experimental way may be
really tricky but it may be
well if emperor's new mind which is
still relevant now in its fifth decade
after publication as any guide it's
surely to be expected that we'll have
various new insights into these
fascinating subjects that you've worked
on and I can't tell you how much we
appreciate you here your graciousness as
always and visiting us and sharing our
ideas and opinions with us are really
very much appreciated so thank you sir
Roger for your visit and we look forward
to many years of continuing to success
well thank you very much and I'm very
excited to see how many have these
experiments and the telescope in Chile
and all that will come along it really
sounds like a very exciting project
thank you very much the only thing we
can be sure of about the future
[Music]
you